excuse the mess this is just kind of our
collect all I saw everything that I know
I'll need eventually gonna have a safe
dry place to put everything
our old nesting box in need of some
repair we're gonna be putting three
pieces of strapping on here to secure
the nest box so I need to drill three
holes
these are self tapping sheetmetal screws
but these holes being rounded you try to
get the self tapper going it's telling
to slide all over the place if you
pre-drill it first with an 8 inch 8 inch
bit it works a lot better four and a
half inches to get it level that's going
to be too much I think let's see what we
can get
then we're going to be screwing a 2x4 on
edge just using these urban quick crimp
clamps in order to get through the
chicken wire you just got slide off the
yellow which is gonna flush up the
bottom end I'm just using two inch deck
screws and for the next one I'm just
going to flush it with the top putting
it on each side so we have three pieces
of strapping 61 inches long two pieces
of 2x4 48 inches long and now we'll go
ahead well mount the nesting box
okay but one screwing on one end so do
like this in first over here pick up on
that
this is a nesting box that was given to
us you so this will be our third time
setting it up and I had this back piece
I took it off come to find out we need
it it holds the bottom pot of the
nesting box in place luckily I still had
it in the back of my truck I had a made
it to the dump yet to throw it away
this back here has an lip on it screw it
all back in I'll show you what we need
that little lip for so this part of the
tray that's setting that's it holds out
of place is this I'll whip this is
the lip on this side then we got these
so I've enjoyed having the pigs out on
the pasture all summer moving on twice a
day and fun they get all excited every
time they get on fresh grass to see what
they can find but now we're getting
darker in the morning and I live here
having to get on the school bus so early
in the morning I'm kind of looking
forward to having the chickens in here
and not having me outside at first thing
in the morning looking around the dark
now be able to have them in here it's a
different season I guess they'll be a
little different in here it'll be kind
of interested in fun I'll be excited
come summer time to get them back out on
pasture so it's funny how the seasons
change and you look forward to different
thing
video is going a little bit long we got
the nest box in I got the hay in so it's
going to be a part too for getting the
chicken coop ready if you liked the
video give it a thumbs up leave comments
down below we really like interacting
with you guys
you have any ideas and new videos you'd
like to see leave them down below -
that'd be great share the video it
really helps
we're on Instagram we're trying to post
photos once a day on Instagram so you
can keep up to date with us there swapna
acres over on Instagram
we're on Facebook one the acres also and
YouTube but posted a video at least at
least a Friday or Saturday night we're
trying to do one during the week we're
hoping to do more we'll see you right
back here for pot - of getting the
winter chicken coop ready for the
chickens
we'll be bringing the girls in before
you know it thanks for watching we'll
see you right back here next time